HERE IN WILMINGTON AT AN EVENT
ABOUT REOPENING SCHOOLS SAFELY.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY LIVE IN
WILMINGTON.
A COURT IS BLOCKING A U.S.
PROSECUTOR FROM OBTAINING
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TAX RETURNS
WHILE THE PRESIDENT’S LAWYERS
CONTINUE TO FIGHT A SUBPOENA
SEEKING THE RECORDS BEAR THE
JUDGE RULED AFTER HEARING BRIEF
ARGUMENTS FROM BOTH SIDES.
THE PRESIDENT’S LAWYERS APPEALED
FOR A STAY, GRANTING MANHATTAN
ATTORNEY’S OFFICE ACCESS TO HIS
TAX RETURNS.
A LAWYER FOR HIS OFFICE HAD
ARGUED FURTHER DELAYS WOULD ONLY
IMPEDE HIS INVESTIGATION.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED HOW >>
NANCY PELOSI VISITED A
SAN FRANCISCO HAIR SALON
YESTERDAY FOR A WASH AND BLOW
OUT, DESPITE LOCAL ORDINANCES
KEEPING SALONS CLOSED AMID THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
SECURITY FOOTAGE OBTAINED BY
FOX NEWS TIME STAMPED MONDAY,
3:08 PACIFIC, SHOWS NANCY PELOSI
WALKING THROUGH THE SALON IN
SAN FRANCISCO WITH WET HAIR AND
WITHOUT A MASK OVER HER MOUTH OR
NOSE.
"THE SPEAKER ALWAYS WEARS A MASK
AND COMPLIES WITH LOCAL COVID
REQUIREMENTS."
THE OWNER CALLED THE WHOLE
INCIDENT OF A SLAP IN THE FACE
BUT HE LETS GO IN-DEPTH ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE TONIGHT HERE
IN PENNSYLVANIA PEERED JOINING
US, VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
A LOT OF SUPPORTERS HERE.
YOU SEE FERTILE GROUND IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Bret: A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM
ON THE GROUND.
JOE BIDEN’S BOYHOOD HOME IS NOT
FAR FROM WHERE WE ARE SEATED BUT
THIS IS TRUMP COUNTRY NOW.
I THINK IT’S BECAUSE OF THE
CHOICE IN THIS ELECTION.
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, THE
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA IS HE
SOMEONE WHO IS KEPT ALL THE
PROMISES HE MADE.
WE REBUILT THE MILITARY, WE
REVITALIZE THE ECONOMY THROUGH
LESS TAXES AND LESS REGULATION.
WE STOOD BY THE RIGHT TO LIFE
AND RELIGIOUS LIBERTY, AND
JOE BIDEN BY CONTRAST, DESPITE
HIS HERITAGE IN THIS AREA, NOW
LEAVE THE PARTY THAT I THINK HAS
BEEN OVERTAKEN BY THE RADICAL
LEFT.
THEY WANT HIGHER TAXES,
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE, OPEN
BORDERS, ABORTION ON DEMAND AND
ACTUALLY WANT TO CUT FUNDING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT I SAW HERE TODAY, WHAT I
SAW ON THE ROAD TO HERE, WE ARE
GOING TO WIN FOR TWO MORE YEARS
FOR PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Bret: VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
WAS IN PENNSYLVANIA YESTERDAY.
HE SAID AMONG OTHER THINGS, DOES
ANYONE BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
LESS VIOLENCE IN AMERICA IF
DONALD TRUMP IS REELECTED.
HOW DID YOU TAKE THAT?
>> I DIDN’T KNOW HOW TO TAKE IT,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
YESTERDAY, WE HEARD JOE BIDEN
KIND OF MOUTH WORDS AGAINST
VIOLENCE IN THE STREETS BUT THEN
HE VERY QUICKLY CRITICIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HE DESCRIBED AN UNWARRANTED
POLICE SHOOTING WHILE AN
INVESTIGATION IS STILL GOING ON.
HE NEVER MENTIONED ANTIFA.
HE NEVER MENTIONED OF THE
RADICAL LEFT MOBS THAT HAVE BEEN
TEARING ASUNDER AND SETTING FIRE
TO MANY OF OUR MAJOR CITIES OVER
THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
I THINK WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NOW, AND THEY SAW IT TODAY IN
KENOSHA WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
VISIT THERE, IS WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT TODAY WHO IS GOING TO
STAND FOR LAW AND ORDER.
WE ARE GOING TO STAND WITH THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WE’RE GOING TO
GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT WE NEED AND WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO CALL ON GOVERNORS
AND MAYORS TO DO THEIR JOB AND
RESTORE ORDER IN THOSE CITIES
WHERE WE’VE SEEN THE KIND OF
VIOLENCE WE’VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
>> Bret: HERE’S MORE FROM THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> THIS IS A SITTING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTING
THIS COUNTRY BUT INSTEAD, HE IS
ROOTING FOR CHAOS AND VIOLENCE.
THE SIMPLE TRUTH IS DONALD TRUMP
FAILED TO PROTECT AMERICA, SO
NOW, HE’S TRYING TO SCARE
AMERICA.
>> Bret: TRYING TO SCARE
AMERICA?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT’S THE KIND
OF RHETORIC THAT PEOPLE HERE IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY SEE STRAIGHT THROUGH.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT ARE THE LEFT
WING MOBS THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
TO RUN ROUGHSHOD IN PLACES LIKE
PORTLAND AND NEW YORK AND
SEATTLE AND OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DAYS IN KENOSHA.
I MEAN, LOOK.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD MONTHS
AGO, INJUSTICE WILL BE SERVED.
BUT THERE IS ALSO NO EXCUSE FOR
THE RIOTING AND THE LOOTING AND
THE VIOLENCE THAT HAS FOLLOWED.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
THEY HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
GOING TO DEMAND THAT GOVERNORS
AND MAYORS IN THESE DEMOCRAT-RUN
CITIES, IN THESE DEMOCRAT
STATES, STEP UP, DO THEIR JOB,
RESTORE LAW AND ORDER AND THAT
IS REALLY THE CHOICE THAT WE
HAVE.
>> Bret: HE DID MENTION JACOB
BLAKE THERE?
>> WELL, JACOB BLAKE, THAT IS A
TRAGIC SITUATION THAT IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION TODAY --
>> Bret: IT’S NOT.
>> WELL, SHOT SEVEN TIMES.
WE GRIEVE AN INCIDENT LIKE THAT,
WE REALLY DO BUT I WANT TO LET
THE INVESTIGATION PLAY OUT.
IT’S REMARKABLE THAT JOE BIDEN
YESTERDAY ANNOUNCED THAT IT WAS
AN UNWARRANTED POLICE SHOOTING
BEFORE WE HAVE ALL THE FACTS IN
PEER BUT FRANKLY, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION,
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA OFTEN
REFLEXIVELY CRITICIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT’S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IN
THE LAST CAMPAIGN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ENJOYED SO MUCH
SUPPORT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT,
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO FOLLOW
THE FACTS, JUSTICE WILL BE
SERVED IN EVERY CASE.
WE ABHOR VIOLENCE IN ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO REFLEXIVELY CONDEMN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS
VICE PRESIDENT, OUR
ADMINISTRATION ARE GOING TO
STAND WITH THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WE ARE TO LET
INVESTIGATIONS PROCEED AND
JUSTICE IS SERVED.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF FACTS, WE
TRY TO GET AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
STORY THE PRESIDENT HAS NOW TOLD
TWICE TO REPORTERS, THAT A
PERSON WAS ON A PLANE, SAID
THERE WERE SIX PEOPLE DRESSED IN
BLACK, FILLED WITH LEADERS,
RIOTERS, ANARCHISTS, PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR TROUBLE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT HE’S TALKING
ABOUT?
>> I THINK WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
REFERRING TO IS ACTUALLY WHAT WE
HEARD IN MANY OF THE CITIES.
I KNOW IN DETROIT THERE WERE A
LARGE NUMBER OF ARRESTS SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO AND THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WERE FROM OUT OF
STATE.
THE SAME THING OCCURRED IN
ARRESTS THAT TOOK PLACE IN
RECENT CITIES.
LOOK, THERE’S SOMETHING GOING ON
HERE WHERE THE RADICAL LEFT,
THESE ANARCHISTS AND ANTIFA ARE
MOVING PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND IT’S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING INTO, WHERE IS THE
FUNDING FOR THIS COMING FROM?
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING --
>> Bret: -- DEFUNDING THIS.
IT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME
TIME.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN ANY ANTIFA VESTS
OR PEOPLE PLANNING THIS
OPERATION.
>> THAT’S ACTUALLY NOT RIGHT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
OVERSEEN ABOUT 300 ARRESTS.
>> Bret: SPECIFICALLY, BUT NOT
SINCE --
>> THE VIOLENCE HAS BROKEN OUT
IN CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO LEAN
INTO THAT EFFORT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WE ARE
GOING TO WORK CLOSELY ON THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND STATE
OFFICIAL SIDE, BUT WE ARE
VIGOROUSLY INVESTIGATING WHERE
THIS IS BEING ORGANIZED FROM.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE RIOTING AND
THE SETTING FIRE OF BUILDINGS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., HE WAS TAKING
PLACE, WE ACTUALLY HEARD THAT
SOME ORGANIZATION WAS
PREPOSITIONING ASSETS AND
RESOURCES AROUND THE CITY.
AND SO I THINK PEOPLE CAN SEE
THIS IS AN ORGANIZED EFFORT IN
PART.
SOME OF IT MAY BE SPONTANEOUS IN
THE RADICAL LEFT CERTAINLY HAS
ITS ADHERENTS IN EVERY CITY IN
THE COUNTRY, BUT WE ARE LOOKING
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TURN TO
COVID AND A SECOND BUT I WANT TO
FACT-CHECK ANOTHER THING.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED TODAY, IT
NEVER ENDS, NOW THEY’RE TRYING
TO SAY THAT YOUR FAVORITE
PRESIDENT, ME, WENT TO THE
MEDICAL CENTER BECAUSE OF
SEVERAL STROKES.
NEVER HAPPENED, FAKE NEWS,
PERHAPS THEY ARE REFERRING TO
ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
HE SAYS IN THE BOOK THAT YOU
WERE PUT ON ALERT TO TAKE
CONTROL, TO TAKE OFFICE,
ESSENTIALLY, IF HE WENT UNDER
FOR ANESTHESIA.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IS IN
EXCELLENT HEALTH.
I’M ALWAYS INFORMED OF THE
PRESIDENT’S MOVEMENTS, OTHER IT
WAS ON THAT DAY OR ANY OTHER
DAY.
I’M INFORMED.
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING OUT OF THE
ORDINARY ABOUT THAT MOMENT OR
THAT DAY.
I JUST REFER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN.
>> Bret: AS FAR AS BEING ON
STANDBY?
>> I DON’T RECALL BEING TOLD TO
BE ON STANDBY.
I WAS INFORMED THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD A DOCTORS
APPOINTMENT, AND --
>> Bret: I DON’T WANT TO
SPECULATE, I JUST WANT TO CLEAR
THAT UP.
>> I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, PART OF
THIS JOB IS YOU ARE ALWAYS ON
STANDBY IF YOU ARE
VICE PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES
UNITED STATES.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN BE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS
AN REMARKABLE GOOD HEALTH, AND
EVERY SINGLE DAY I SEE THAT
ENERGY AND HIGH RELIEF.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
COVID.
IN HINDSIGHT, DO YOU THINK THE
LOCKDOWNS WERE A MISTAKE?
>> I DON’T.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT WHEN
THE PRESIDENT MADE THE DECISION
TO SUSPEND ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA, WHEN HE STOOD UP, THE
LARGEST NATIONAL MOBILIZATION
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
WHEN WE ASKED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR WHAT BECAME 45 DAYS
TO SLOW THE SPREAD, I THINK WE
SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
AND THOSE LOCKDOWNS PERMITTED US
TO STAND UP.
IT LITERALLY BILLIONS OF
SUPPLIES TO HER DOCTORS AND
NURSES AND HOSPITALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, MANUFACTURED MORE THAN
THAN 100 DAYS.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THE
SACRIFICES PEOPLE MADE DURING
THAT TIME MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR
US TO ENSURE THAT NO AMERICAN
WHO REQUIRED A VENTILATOR WAS
EVER DENIED A VENTILATOR.
OUR DOCTORS AND NURSES HAD THE
PPE WE REQUIRED.
WE WERE ABLE TO REINVENT TESTING
WHERE WE WERE DOING 800,000
TESTS A DAY.
MORE TO COME WITH THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OF THIS LAST WEEK.
ULTIMATELY, IT PUT US IN A PLACE
WHERE EVERY SINGLE DAY, I THINK
WE ARE ONE DAY CLOSER TO THE DAY
WE HAVE THAT VACCINE IN ADDITION
TO THE THERAPEUTICS WE HAVE THAT
WILL PUT THIS CORONAVIRUS IN THE
PAST.
>> Bret: I GUESS I WONDER IF
YOU LOOK BACK AND THINK YOU
COULD’VE DONE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
WE LEARNED A LOT AS THE VIRUS
WAS CONTINUING.
YOU’VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
WEARING MASKS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WEAR A MASK WHENEVER YOUR
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES SAY
IT’S APPROPRIATE.
IT’S ALWAYS A GOOD IDEA TO WEAR
A MASK WHEN SOCIAL DISTANCING IS
NOT POSSIBLE.
>> WHAT FURTHER EVIDENCE DOES
ANYONE NEED THAT THIS PRESIDENT
COULDN’T CARE LESS ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS THEN TO SEE
WHAT HE DID, VANDALIZING, BY THE
WAY, MY HOUSE, BY BRINGING ALL
THOSE PEOPLE THERE.
NO MASKS, NO DISTANCING AND THE
REST.
HE SLAPPED SCIENCE RIGHT IN THE
FACE.
>> Bret: TALKING ABOUT THE
SPEECH THERE ON THE SOUTH LAWN,
AND A MASK, NO DISTANCE.
RESPOND, IF YOU WOULD COME INTO
THE HOUSE SPEAKER.
>> I APPRECIATE THE SPEAKER’S
CONCERNED ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I
TRUST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
GIVE THE PEOPLE THE BEST
INFORMATION AND PEOPLE MAKE
DECISIONS, WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
MOST APPROPRIATE TO THEIR
HEALTH.
THAT AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS NOT
ONLY INSPIRING BUT WE ALSO
PROVIDED MASKS TO ANYONE THAT
WANTED ONE.
HAND CLEANERS AND SANITIZERS.
BUT WHAT’S REMARKABLE TO ME IS
THAT NANCY PELOSI HAD, TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, NOT A WORD TO SAY
ABOUT THE GATHERING THAT TOOK
PLACE OUTSIDE THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL THE NEXT DAY.
LITERALLY THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS ALL
GATHERED.
BUT I WOULD SAY IN BOTH CASES,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE
EXERCISING THOSE GOD-GIVEN
RIGHTS ENSHRINED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION TO PEACEABLY
ASSEMBLE.
WE DID IT ON THE SOUTH ON
THURSDAY NIGHT AND THEY DID IT
OUTSIDE THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL ON
FRIDAY, AND I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS A CHOICE BETWEEN MANY
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
SIMPLY WANT ONCE AGAIN TO TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT TO DO,
AND A PRESIDENT AND A TEAM IN
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT REALLY
TRUSTS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
PUT THE HEALTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND OUR COUNTRY FIRST.
>> Bret: IT YOU ARE NOW
OPPONENT SENATOR, HARRIS TWEETED
THIS, NEARLY 183,000 AMERICANS
HAVE DIED FROM CORONAVIRUS.
MORE THAN 16 MILLION OUT OF
WORK.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CAN’T GO BACK TO CAMPUS, MORE
THAN 110,000 SMALL BUSINESSES
CLOSED FOR GOOD.
THIS IS TRUMP’S AMERICA.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> THERE IS NOT A DAY GOES BY
THAT I DON’T THINK OF THE
FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED ONES.
AS I SAID IN PENNSYLVANIA TODAY,
MORE THAN 7,000 AMERICANS IN
THIS STATE PASSED AWAY, AND I
WANT THOSE FAMILIES TO KNOW THEY
WILL ALWAYS BE IN OUR HEARTS AND
IN OUR PRAYERS.
BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THAT HAD PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT
SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL FROM CHINA,
BEFORE WE HAD A SINGLE CASE OF
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION IN THIS
COUNTRY, HAD HE NOT SCREWED UP
THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE, HAD
WE NOT SUSPENDED TRAVEL FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THEN USED
THAT TIME WORKING WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, 45 DAYS TO SLOW
THE SPREAD, PROVIDED NEARLY
$4 TRILLION IN RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES THAT HAS NOW CREATED
A FOUNDATION WHERE IN THE LAST
THREE MONTHS WE’VE ALREADY SEEN
9 MILLION AMERICANS GO BACK TO
WORK.
I THINK THE COMBINATION OF ALL
OF THOSE, FOR FAIR-MINDED
AMERICANS LOOKING ON, THEY KNOW
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS LED
US THROUGH ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIMES IN MY LIFETIME
AND HE HAS LED THE WAY THE PUT
THE HEALTH OF AMERICA FIRST.
>> Bret: LAST TIME YOU FACE
SENATOR TIM GAME.
HERE’S A LITTLE PIECE OF THAT
FROM THE DEBATE.
>> DONALD TRUMP SUPPORTS OUR
VETERANS.
>> HE WON’T PAY TAXES.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS PAID ALL THE
TAXES -- HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> AMERICANS NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER DONALD TRUMP WILL BE
LOOKING OUT FOR AMERICA’S BOTTOM
LINE OR HIS OWN BOTTOM LINE.
>> Bret: IT’S A DIFFERENT
PERSON YOU’RE FACING IN
KAMALA HARRIS BUT ALONG THE
TAXES LINE, WHY HAVEN’T THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEEN THE
PRESIDENT’S TAXES?
AT FIRST IT WAS YEARS OF, HE’S
UNDER AN AUDIT.
NOW HIS LAWYERS ARE SPENDING A
LOT OF TIME FIGHTING A SUBPOENA
TO TRY TO GET THE TAXES.
WHY NOT PUT THEM OUT AHEAD OF
THIS ELECTION?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS RESPONDED
TO THAT MANY TIMES.
AS I SAID IN THAT VERY SAME
DEBATE, THE PRESIDENT LITERALLY
HAS PRODUCED HUNDREDS OF PAGES
OF FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES, WHICH
IS WHAT THE LAW REQUIRES.
BUT YOU KNOW, DIFFERENT FROM THE
TIME I WAS SITTING FOR THE
DEBATE AND TODAY, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ACTUALLY VOTED FOR TWO
YEARS AGO TO ELECT A
DONALD TRUMP TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Bret: SO YOU THINK THAT
ENDS THAT ISSUE?
>> LOOK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR BOTTOM
LINE AND THEIR INCOME THAN ABOUT
THE INCOME OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
I REALLY BELIEVE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE FACT THAT IN OUR FIRST
THREE YEARS, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT KEPT HIS WORD TO THE
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA AND CUT
TAXES FOR BUSINESSES LARGE AND
SMALL AND WORKING FAMILIES,
ROLLED BACK MORE REGULATION THAN
ANY ADMINISTRATION IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, WE UNLEASHED AMERICAN
ENERGY SO THAT STATES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA ARE NOW PART OF AN
AMERICAN ENERGY RENAISSANCE.
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY HAS
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ABOLISH
FOSSIL FUELS.
I KNOW HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT
I’M NOT BANNING SLACKING, BUT
THAT FLIES IN THE FACE OF WHAT
HE HAS SAID OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN OVER THE PAST YEAR
YEAR.
HIS VERSION OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, THEY WILL MAKE GOOD ON A
BEER JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE BEEN
OVERTAKEN BY THE RADICAL LEFT.
THAT’S AN AGENDA TO ABOLISH
AMERICAN ENERGY.
I THINK THE ENTHUSIASM YOU SAW
IN PENNSYLVANIA TODAY TELLS YOU
THAT THIS PRESIDENT’S COMMITMENT
TO LESS TAXES, MORE JOBS, MORE
AMERICAN ENERGY IS GOING TO BE A
WINNING MESSAGE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Bret: I’VE GOT TO HIT A
BREAK AND I COULD TALK TO YOU
ALL DAY WITH A LOT OF QUESTIONS
BUT TWO VERY QUICK ONES.
ONE, WILL THE PRESIDENT ASSURE
THAT THERE IS NOT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN?
AND IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS BILL, WHATEVER IT
IS, IS GOING TO BE TIED TO THAT
EFFORT?
>> WE ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH LEADERS IN
CONGRESS ABOUT ANOTHER
CORONAVIRUS, AND I CAN TELL YOU,
NOBODY WANTS TO SEND MORE
SUPPORT TO AMERICAN FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES THEN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, BUT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW DEMOCRATS
IN CONGRESS --
>> Bret: THE GOVERNMENT
WON’T --
>> TO USE THE CORONAVIRUS BILL
TO BASICALLY BAIL OUT BADLY RUN
DEMOCRAT STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
WE’RE GOING TO STAND FIRM, BUT
THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF OPTIONS.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THROUGH THIS
CHALLENGING TIME.
WE ARE GOING TO BE THERE TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES, SUPPORT
BUSINESSES AND WE ARE GOING TO
BRING AMERICA ALL THE WAY BACK
WITH FOUR MORE YEARS OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Bret: VICE PRESIDENT, WE